[Musique]
beethoven est sans contredit le des plus
grands compositeurs de tous les temps
malheureusement il n'a pas pu compléter
sa dixième symphonie serait-il possible
de la terminer aujourd'hui avec l'aide
de l'intelligence artificielle
sur les eaux calmes du lac léman en
suisse une formidable histoire s'écrit à
partir de gribouille
voici la dixième symphonie de beethoven
telle qu'elle était à la mort du
compositeur en 1827 une oeuvre inachevée
incomplète
mais que serait cette symphonie si
beethoven avait pu la terminer
c'est la question au coeur de la quête
de florian colombo
[Musique]
la musique pour moi c'est la vie c'est
ma vie
l'archet de florian vibre au rythme des
symphonies de beethoven depuis sa
jeunesse dès l'adolescence il fait vivre
l'oeuvre du prodige allemand au sein de
son orchestre
depuis toujours ce violoncelle est plus
qu'une passion sans besoin
aujourd'hui spécialiste en neurosciences
computationnelle il veut s'attaquer à
quelque chose de gros d'énormes
compléter la dixième symphonie non pas
par ses propres moyens les avec l'aide
de l'intelligence artificielle
[Musique]
mais comment insuffler à un ordinateur
le style de beethoven comment compléter
une création entamé il ya deux cents ans
la première partie a été de prendre des
partitions des quatuors à cordes de
beethoven sous format numérique de ses
partitions j'ai récupéré les
informations sur les rythmes des notes
la hauteur des notes des différentes
voix d'ordinateur entend la musique
grâce à un réseau de neurones
artificiels
de la même manière que l'humain entend
grâce aux neurones de son oreille
interne chez l'ordinateur chaque neurone
est programmée au s'activer en fonction
d'une note précise par exemple tel
neurones s'activera en présence d'un dos
tel autre pour 1 me mon algorithmes
puisqu'il va faire c'est qu'il va
analyser ces notes il va analyser les
choix de beethoven essayer de comprendre
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a mis telle note à
tel endroit en fonction du contexte
mais avant de s'attaquer à la dixième
symphonie l'intelligence artificielle
doit se pratiquer avec d'autres oeuvres
du compositeur
[Musique]
question ne maîtrisais toute la
structure et la logique derrière
l'oeuvre de beethoven florian lui
présente des partitions auquel il a
intentionnellement retirer des notes la
kelly jans artificielle s'entraîne ainsi
à prédire les notes manquantes pour
compléter les partitions
certaines parties on n'a pas le choix
c'est clair la levure et nous dit ça
peut qu'être cette note là mais sur
d'autres partis il ya deux ou trois
notes qui sont probables et on doit
choisir parmi sa note là alors dans ces
cas là il ya de l'aléatoire qui rentre
en compte
[Musique]
l'intelligence artificielle vérifie si
ces prédictions sont justes elle est
programmée de manière à pouvoir comparer
les notes qu'elle devine à celle de la
partition d'origine en fonction du
résultat obtenu elle s'ajuste eux le
processus continue ainsi jusqu'à ce que
ces prédictions soit fiable
après des mois d'entraînement
l'intelligence artificielle est prête
pour le test ultime
florian peut enfin lui remetre les notes
laissées par beethoven deux cents ans
plus tôt en quelques minutes
l'ordinateur complètent leur
[Musique]
2 septembre 2021 lausanne suisse en
matinée c'est la répétition générale
l' orchestre nexus découvre l'oeuvre
pour la première fois la symphonie de
florian ou du moins celles créées par
son algorithme prend vie il ya eu
beaucoup de doutes beaucoup de trac mais
une fois que j'avais fait ma partie
c'était hors de mon contrôle donc là
j'ai juste pu apprécier
20 heures début du concert
l'excitation est à son comble tout d'un
coup découvrir cette musique finalement
jouée sur des vrais instruments c'était
très satisfaisant et ouvre
les experts présents au concert chacun
pour dire qu'on reconnaît bien la touche
de beethoven mais qu'il manque
l'étincelle du génie je ne pense pas que
beethoven ne serait jamais remplacer
mais je pense qu'il allait c'est beau de
belles partitions sur lesquels on peut
travailler créer des nouvelles choses en
utilisant le savoir qui nous a légué à
travers ses partitions
ce concert sonne-t-il la fin de la quête
de floria pas tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
je veux offrir la chance à n'importe qui
au gens qui ne sont pas forcément
musiciens la possibilité de s'exprimer à
travers la composition musicale parce
que je viens
florian ne souhaite pas remplacer les
compositeurs par l'intelligence
artificielle mais plutôt la mettre à
leur service ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les musiciens est d'autant
plus les compositeurs professionnels qui
utiliseraient ces outils ben du coup il
se serait vraiment un est de liseron
probablement résultats bien meilleurs
que quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas la
musique sur son voilier le
violoncelliste ne peut s'empêcher
d'avoir une pensée pour les grands
maîtres de la musique classique
je pense que les compositeurs une
géniaux comme beethoven je pense qu'ils
auraient été très curieux
[Musique]